Nos piden simplificar "9p" elevado a la 2/3
y eso dividido entre la raíz cuadrada de "4p" cúbica.
Hagámoslo paso a paso.
Lo primero que podemos hacer es,
aquí tenemos "9p" a la 2/3
y esto lo podemos escribir como
9 a la 2/3 que multiplica a "p" elevado a la 2/3,
este "9p" a la 2/3,
lo puedo separar de esa manera,
la parte de abajo, esta raíz cuadrada de "4p" cúbica
la podemos reescribir como
4 por "p" cúbica elevado a la 1/2,
esto es lo mismo, la raíz cuadrada de 4p cúbica
es exactamente lo mismo que
"4p" cúbica, elevado a la potencia 1/2.
Dado eso podemos hacer lo mismo
que hicimos aquí en el numerador,
es decir, esto es igual a 4 elevado a la 1/2,
que multiplica a "p" al cubo elevado a la 1/2...
que multiplica a "p"al cubo elevado a la 1/2.
Veamos ahora cómo simplificar esto.
Hagamos primero el denominador,
esto es igual a...
en el denominador tenemos 4 al 1/2
que es lo mismo que raíz cuadrada de 4,
que es igual a 2, que multiplica a "p" al cubo
elevado al 1/2,
que es lo mismo que "p" elevado a la 3 por 1/2,
que es lo mismo que "p" elevado a la 3/2...
"p" elevado a la 3/2.
Ahora el numerador, 9 a la 2/3.
Bueno, la raíz cúbica de 9,
no es nada que podamos simplificar,
o lo podemos ver como 9 al cuadrado....
Déjame hacerlo de la siguiente manera,
9 a la 2/3 lo podemos simplificar como...
bueno, no lo vamos a simplificar,
pero vamos a escribirlo de la siguiente manera, que nos va a permitir calcularlo fácilmente,
9 a la 2/3 es lo mismo que 9 al cuadrado,
elevado a la potencia 1/3, de acuerdo.
Aquí tenemos 9 elevado a la 2 por 1/3 que es lo mismo que 9 elevado a la 2/3
y esto multiplicado por "p" elevado a la 2/3
y esto va a ser igual a 9 al cuadrado es 81,
81 elevado a la potencia 1/3 que multiplica a
"p"
elevado a la potencia 2/3,
y ahora el denominador en vez de poner el denominador como está,
voy a usar exponentes negativos para expresarlo,
así es que
este 2 que tenemos aquí,
equivale a 2 elevado a la -1,
lo cual equivale a 1/2,
así es que vamos a multiplicar por 1/2,
este 1/2 equivale a este 2 que tenemos aquí
y "p" elevado a la 3/2 es lo mismo que "p"
elevado a la menos...
elevado a la -3/2.
Así que por lo pronto la expresión original
la hemos simplificado en ésta.
Déjame copiar esto y pegarlo donde sea
más cómodo trabajarlo...
entonces, copiamos y pegamos...
vamos a moverlo un poco a la izquierda,
para proceder a simplificar más aún esta expresión.
Veamos cómo podemos reescribir 81 a la 1/3.
Básicamente cuando elevas al cubo...
bueno más bien cuando elevas a la 1/3 algo,
estás sacando la raíz cúbica de ese algo,
saquemos factores primos de 81
para ver si tenemos algunos cubos perfectos.
Así es que 81 lo podemos
escribir como 3 por 27,
27 es 3 por 9,
y finalmente 9 es 3 por 3,
así es que 81 es
3, por 3, por 3, por 3,
3 a la cuarta,
de tal manera que este 81 a la 1/3
es equivalente escribirlo como
3 por 3, por 3,
3 al cubo que va aquí ,
y aún así multiplicarlo por 3 nuevamente.
Esto elevado a la 1/3,
es lo mismo que 81 elevado a la 1/3.
Veamos ahora las "p",
y aquí estoy haciendo más pasos
de lo que haría normalmente,
porque quiero que entiendas qué es lo que hay detrás
de las simplificaciones que hacemos.
Tenemos "p" a la 2/3 que multiplica a "p" a la -3/2
eso equivale a "p"
elevado a la 2/3 menos 3/2,
ya sólo nos queda multiplicar por este 1/2,
así es que por 1/2, bien.
Ahora, ¿a qué es igual esto?
Esto es igual a...
esto lo podemos escribir como 3 por 3, por 3 y por 3,
lo vamos a separar como 3 por 3, por 3,
elevado a la 1/3
que multiplica a 3 elevado a la 1/3,
esto lo hemos hecho ya varias veces,
que multiplica a "p" elevado a la 2/3 menos 3/2,
¿esto a qué es igual?
Hagámoslo acá arriba,
como 3/2 es mayor y es negativo,
esto es igual a -3/2 menos 2/3,
para hacer esta resta sacamos común denominador,
6 es el común denominador de 3 y 2,
entonces si pasamos 3/2 a sextos, esto es equivalente
a 9/6, mientras que 2/3 equivale a 4/6.
Ahora si hacemos la resta
9/6 menos 4/6 es 5/6,
con el signo menos que tenemos antes,
esto es -5/6,
esto es entonces igual a "p" elevado a la -5/6,
que multiplica a 1/2,
que multiplica a este último término, 1/2.
Ahora 3 por 3, por 3 a la 1/3,
27 a la 1/3,
la raíz cúbica de 27 es 3,
así  es que esto de aquí equivale a 3,
que multiplica a 3 a la 1/3 es la raíz cúbica de 3.
Así es que esto lo podemos escribir, este término de aquí lo puedo escribir como la raíz cúbica de 3,
y luego tenemos "p" a la - 5/6...
vamos a escribirla aquí...
aunque de hecho en ocasiones se pone estos términos antes del radical, vamos a hacerlo así.
Borremos esta raíz cúbica de 3 para poner "p" a la -5/6
y eso que multiplica...
ahora sí vamos a poner la raíz cúbica de 3
y eso finalmente,multiplicando por, 1/2,
lo que es equivalente a dividir entre 2 toda la expresión.
Y ya hemos logrado una buena simplificación,
aunque quizás estos 3/2 los podías poner como 1.5
que multiplica a "p" a la -5/6
que multiplica a la raíz cúbica de 3.
Si quieres puedes calcular la raíz cúbica de 3 y multiplicarla por 1.5,
para obtener un número decimal
multiplicado por "p" a la -5/6,
y esa es, la mejor simplificación,
que podemos lograr.